if you're a connected person today
you've probably got Facebook Twitter
Instagram maybe some fine fine and a
little periscope on your phone but here
comes a new mobile social app called
peach no idea why it's called that think
of it as a mash-up of Twitter and a slag
group chat it's fun you're not
broadcasting your feed to the world goes
to an audience of friends other people
can see you but only if they look for
you it's not private like snapchat so
careful with what you post it works like
this there's a timeline where you can
read an old-school status update you can
post a photo or make a looping video
type the word gif or Jif and it'll
search for one based on your terms the
gifts gifts are the gateway drug to a
peach calls magic words terms that give
some unique functionality and really set
peach apart type TV and the first word
of the show's title and it'll suggest a
few for you it knows what's on now you
can tell people what you're watching
other magic words access cool features
like your phone's pedometer or the local
weather you can even doodle with the
draw function
don't judge me don't want to write about
yourself find a friend and scroll the
bottom of their feet you can send a wave
or some other bizarre action like orange
any number hitting them with a piece of
cake I just cake Joe so what's the point
don't know maybe the point isn't a point
it's a fun app with some neat features
it cleverly blends the intimacy of
messaging with the Leanback boy or as a
movie Facebook style newsfeed that is if
any of your friends start using it
here's hoping cake me
you